- So, speaking of looking great,
y'all look so great in that.
So on your recent press tour,
you said that you didn't feel comfortable
wearing natural hairstyles
while in the White House.
So what exactly do you mean by that?
- You know, a lot of
people don't remember,
as the first black family
in the White House,
the, the journey there wasn't smooth.
There were people who tried to-
- I Remember the news.
Yeah.
- Turn us into others.
- Yeah, division.
- And so,
we had to overcome a lot of that.
And so much was read into
gestures we would make,
like a fist bump was turned into a
terrorist fish jab.
And so I was like, braids,
people aren't gonna understand braids.
Sadly. Not at least at that time.
And I didn't want that
to be a distraction.
There was too much to do.
There was healthcare to-
- You didn't want to
distract from the focus.
- Right.
Now, fortunately, the, more people
are showing what it means to be beautiful,
what hair can look like.
I'm grateful to this generation
that is owning every part of themselves.
(audience claps)
- Absolutely.
- So, now-
- A very bold generation.
And it's good.
- And, and we need it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause we need to
create a broader definition
of who's American,
who counts, what beauty is.
It only helps our kids, who are,
we don't know who they're gonna become.
And we wanna make sure
there's a space for them
whoever they choose to be.
- Why limit them? Yeah.
I think it, it should be celebrated.
And I think you're right.
This younger generation
is very much into that.
- Yeah. And it shouldn't be politicized.
- Yeah.
- Most kids who are
wearing tattoos and piercings,
they've got long nails.
It's not about their, their value system.
is about individuality.
- But back in the day,
tattoos was like so bad.
- It, well, and-
- And I came home with one,
and my mom just kind of
looked at it and was like,
"That's new."
(everyone laughs)
- Well, it was the same thing.
My generation didn't,
we didn't, tattoos meant
something totally different.
- [Kelly] I know.
- We used to
threaten our kids that
if you get a tattoo,
we're gonna get exactly the same kind
and show it on TikTok or whatever.
(Kelly laughs)
- Take the cool away.
- Take the cool all away.
(Kelly laughs hysterically)
- That's a good parenting skill.
- Just like we're gonna make it so uncool.
Barack Obama's gonna have
a heart on his shoulder.
(Kelly laughs hysterically)
(audience applauds)
- That was the greatest
mom tip of the day.